but let's do this last one okay I'm
gonna do the expansion the reason why is
because I see you carefully the reason I
do expansion the reason I bother with it
at all
is because I know that something simpler
than this will be once I put this X and
X together will give me an x squared you
create that so there x squared there but
there's also an x squared here should be
things I can love to get in one heap and
I don't need to write us any x okay so
let's do the expansion without the SS x
times four minus X what am I going to
get first up for X I'm gonna take away
and we just established it thanks it
actually be x squared plus and then the
three goes up to everything in the
second pair of brackets so 3x squared
takeaway
so in fact it looks like I can combine
in a couple of beads you write minus x
squared plus 3x squared 3 minus 1 3
minus 1 is 2 and 4 X minus 3 X X now
I'll just make a quick note because I
sort of did it without explaining what
did you go ahead collecting like to
write and you have more than one list of
things you need to actually combine it's
in your interest to do it thing a little
bit of board all right
I did the X Squared's first and then I
move on to the X's kind of what I didn't
say but I was doing in the back of my
head is I just look at the power and I
drew the biggest ones first and then I
go down otherwise this Christmas you
can't hit a little bit we won't do them
this topic much we if you remember
quadratic equations from La si do you
remember these guys we tend to write
them in this exact order with the big
comes first and the small ones layer and
when there's no power we leave at the
end because they don't know why we
bother doing that
like why is that a sensible way to do
it's okay if you don't I will explain
you know Booz Allen random because math
is about you sake because Karina let me
say why okay because everything is
always for a reason X is some number we
don't know what it is that's the whole
point of algae right but X could be some
astronomically large number like a
million or population has been it 24
million or population well it's a seven
point whatever billion is implanted now
if the number is really big
they clearly like the most important
thing are these one two three terms the
most important thing will be the biggest
number times itself on the big things
number cubed or the biggest under power
of four
whichever is largest will be the most
significant and six will just kind of
vanished on to the end okay I keep in
mind it could be exactly gathering
around my ex could be something really
tiny and then it's the least important
thing the point is I don't know right
like I have to kind of leave it in
videos so therefore I leave it the fun
because often it is very very large so
it's the term that matters the reason
why I draw it out here is because you
want to have some order just so you
don't mix it up once you're gonna forget
any terms like that I shall make sure I
get all of them and I've accounted for
everything and colors will help me make
sure you not miss anything okay